Public Sénat France 24 et RFI
[Musique]
présent bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'Europe nous sommes
ensemble sur France24 et Radio France
Internationale en cette semaine
où l'actualité est toujours aussi
tragique bien sûr au Proche Orient et
aux quatre coins du monde après quelques
ququ et bien les 27 tentent d'afficher
un peu d'unité sur les grands dossier
grand dossier diplomatique mais aussi
économique et nous en parlons tout de
suite avec Laurence boun bonjour vous
êtes la secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'Europe dans le gouvernement
d'Élisabeth borne depuis 2022 où est
l'Europe que fait l'Europe il y a eu par
exemple mardi une réunion extraordinaire
des 27 pour clarifier leur position sur
le conflit avec Israël non seulement
l'Union européenne semble avoir peu
d'impact dans cette région mais surtout
elle a une position plus que confuse ces
dernières semaines euh pas du tout
vraiment je peux pas vous laisser dire
ça c'est c'est c'est pas juste d'abord
Charles Michel qui est le président du
Conseil européen comme vous savez a
publi
un communiqué qui a été revu par les 27
en amont de la réunion de mardi donc
aussitôt que que le weekend dernier très
rapidement après après les attaques
terroristes contre Israël et la deuxième
chose
c'est ce communiqué était donc précédait
la Réunion où les 27 ont pu exprimer
leur position leurs coverence et comment
ils allaient effectivement se coordonner
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent on sent quand même des des
sensibilités un peu différentes la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula van derleyon lors de son séjour
en Israël a soutenu le droit d'Israël à
se défendre sans ajouter que cette
réponse devait se faire conformément au
droit humanitaire et international
c'était un qui que c'était insuffisant
finalement ça n'est que sa position le
Conseil européen et les 27 chefs d'État
et de gouvernement des 27 pays membres
de l'Union européenne se sont exprimés
exactement tous sur la même ligne
condamne les attaques terroristes du
Hamas contre Israël le droit d'Israël
évidemment à répliquer dans le respect
du droit humanitaire et du droit
international mais donc du coup le
l'Union européenne prévoit le triplement
de son aide humanitaire porté à 75
millions d'euros pour la bande de Gaza
les 27 se disent prêts à continuer à
soutenir les civils qui en ont le plus
besoin à Gaza en veillant à ce que cette
assistance ne se ne fasse pas l'objet
d'une utilisation abusive par des
organisation terroriste c'est-à-dire le
le Hamas est-ce que c'est possible à
vérifier vraiment mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on dit ça l'Union européenne n pas du
tout naïve et bien évidemment la
première chose d'ailleurs que que nous
avons que j'ai demandé à l'Union
européenne c'est de vérifier que tous
les fonds qui étaient destinés à Gaza
allaient bien à de l'aide humanitaire et
le président de la République lui-même
l'a dit à l'éducation à l'aide
alimentaire et à de l'eau potable et
évid
la France comme l'Union européenne ont
augmenté ont accru un peu leur aide
humanitaire dans des circonstances que
je suis sûr vous comprendrez bien sont
très difficiles pour les civils de Gaza
et évidemment comme le la situation est
compliqué et que le Hamas est aussi à
Gaza il y a besoin de vérification
accrue et c'est pour ça qu'on explique
que ça passera par le sud de la bande de
Gaza par l'Égypte et qu'on fera très
attention à la fois protéger les civils
et à ce qui bénéficient de cette aide en
France l'auteur de de la attaque au
couteau un homme de de nationalité russe
20 ans qui a tué un enseignant dans dans
le lycée d'aras c'était effectivement
cette semaine aussi très très émouvant
cet enterrement à haras euh il a publié
une vidéo de
revendication revendique son geste au
nom de de l'organisation état islamique
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit finalement
notre rapport au monde peut-être notre
rapport à l'enseignement aussi Laurence
boun d'abord je vais avoir une pensée
pour pour la famille pour les étudiants
les lycéens qui étaient dans ce lycée
j'ai des enfants qui sont au lycée je
viens d'une famille de professeurs et je
trouve qu'émotionnellement c'est c'est
absolument terrible et que la date
presque 3 ans jour pour jour après ce
qui est arrivé à Samuel Patti n'est
absolument pas innocente la deuxième
chose c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
s'attaque à l'école parce que l'école
c'est la connaissance contre les
contre les idéologies qu'ell soi
religieuses ou autrees c'est ce qui
apporte aux personnes la capacité de
s'émanciper de vivre librement de faire
des choix c'est tout ce qui représente
la démocratie le savoir contre
l'obscurantisme et il faut absolument
qu'on en ait vraiment conscience parce
que c'est à ça que nous en retour on
doit s'attaquer à ces personnes qui
s'attaquent à nos liberté et à nos
démocratie vous savez cette semaine
j'étais avec la première ministre
d'Estonie kal ils ne vivent que depuis
30 ans dans une démocratie elle est plus
jeune que nous elle a des mots pour
rappeler à tous les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
que la démocratie ça n'est jamais acquis
et je pense que c'est ça la leçon
l'héritage qui nous oblige de ce que ce
professeur très courageux a fait alors
autre autre attentat cette fois à
Bruxelles effectivement d'un Tunisien de
45 ans en séjour irrégulier en Belgique
il s'en est pris à des à des Suédois
cette fois en raison d'autodafé du
corant dans ce pays quelle quelle leçon
vous tirez vous de de ce qui s'est passé
en Belgique ce que je vois c'est que on
na pas un problème spécifiquement
français ou un sujet spécifiquement
français c'est un sujet européen la
situation mondiale est très tendue
évidemment ce qui s'est passé au proches
Orient et inquiétant c'est pour ça que
le Président de la République multiplie
ses appels c'est pour ça que Catherine
Colona s'est rendue sur place et ensuite
c'est un sujet sur lequel on doit
travailler en européen vous l'avez
mentionné au début il y a eu cette
réunion des 27 dans 10 jours il y aura
de nouveau un Conseil européen moi-même
j'en ai un dans une semaine et c'est
cette coordination à la fois dans la
réponse dans l'aide à Israël et dans la
réponse pour les Palestiniens civils
cette coordination sur les affaires
intérieur à l'Union européenne elle est
essentielle parce que ce que cherche à
faire toutes ces personnes c'est à nous
diviser pour saper les fondements de
notre démocratie et donc la seule
réponse la réponse qui doit à notre
boussole ça doit être de rester uni face
à cet ADV et renforcer les frontières
vous dites que en l'occurrence quel
quelles sont les les pistes finalement
ébauchées dans ces dans le cas de ces
attentats si c'est vous qui venez de le
dire je rappelle c'était des gens qui
étaient sur notre territoire évidemment
les frontières de l'Union européenne
sont renforcés ça fait longtemps qu'on
travaille d'ailleurs là-dessus c'est un
des résultats de la présidence française
de l'Union européenne une montée en
puissance jusqu'à 10000 personnes
d'agents Frontex qui vont renforcer nos
nos frontières exteres et après
et Gérald Darmanin l'a dit plusieurs
fois quand il y a une menace sur notre
territoire et une menace terroriste bien
évidemment nous renforçons aussi les
frontières à l'intérieur c'est prévu
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne on
part en direction de l'est de l'Europe
en Pologne c'est la victoire bonne
nouvelle pour l'Union européenne en tout
cas c'est la victoire aux élections de
l'opposition très
pro-européenne emmené par d'ailleurs un
ancien président du Conseil le polonais
Donald tousk après 8 ans d'un parti
ultra conservateur Droit et Justice avec
une rhtorique souvent
anti-Bruxelles est-ce que vous y voyez
un symbole peut-être même un coup
d'arrêt au populisme c'est fantastique
ce qui s'est passé en Pologne absolument
fantastique d'abord à plein de points de
vue d'abord on a une un taux de
participation très élevé il a pris près
de 15 points c'est 74 % des Polonais qui
sont allés voter vous vous rendez compte
par rapport à ce qu'on voit c'est
colossal c'est colossal aussi parce que
ce sont les jeunes qui sont allés voter
63 % des jeunes entre 18 et 29 ans sont
allés voter si je vous dis combien de
pourcent des jeunes vont voter aux
élections européennes chez nous entre 18
et 24 ans c'est à peine 25 % donc il
faut bien se rendre compte et ça c'est
j'ai envie de dire c'est un appel à la
jeunesse que quand on va voter on peut
changer le cours des choses et la
troisième chose avec ces élections qui
est aussi remarquable c'est qu'il y
avait en même temps un référendum sur
l'immigration et celui-là il y a eu que
40 % des gens qui sont allés voter donc
le référendum n'est même pas valide
quelle que soit la réponse qui a été
apporter donc c'est un vrai retour c'est
un retournement de situation et on va
pas cacher notre plaisir de voir des
gens qui ne sont pas populistes qui ont
envie de travailler en européen même
s'ils sont plus conservateurs que notre
gouvernement que le gouvernement auquel
j'appartiens on va pouvoir travailler
avec des personnes qui pense de façon
républicaine et en direction
pro-européenne euh vous vous attendez à
ce que Varsovie puisse revenir à l'état
de droit et en particulier dans son
système judiciaire peut-être aussi dans
ce qui était appliqué en matière de
droits des femmes et de minorités
sexuelles et ethnique assez vite ou au
contraire alors il y aura la lourdeur de
de l'appareil alors c'est je pense un
point extrêmement important d'abord
parce que le premier parti qui est
arrivé en tête reste le parti populiste
et donc va essayer de former un
gouvernement même s'il a très peu de
chance il a quasiment aucune chance d'y
arriver ils sont là ils ont changé aussi
en profondeur les structures de l'État
et même quand le gouvernement
pro-européen la coalition sera sera
nommé il va falloir inverser tout ce qui
a été fait pour verrouiller les
structures de l'État et là j'ai envie de
dire c'est un appel aux électeurs
français attention il est difficile il
va falloir travailler dans la durée pour
les Polonais de renverser ces structures
et de remettre en place des structures
qui soient démocratiques équilibré juste
et qui sont dans l'intérêt général et
pas dans l'intérêt d'un parti d'ailleurs
au moment de la campagne il y a eu même
au-delà là des des dossiers de politique
intérieure et de fâcherie avec Bruxelles
il y a eu aussi un changement de cap sur
l'Ukraine de cette Pologne qui ne
voulait qui avait des problèmes avec le
blé ukrainien et qui ne voulait plus
livrer du tout d'armes à à l'Ukraine
qu'est-ce qu'il va en être ah mais là
c'est une erreur majeure de la campagne
du pis d'abord parce que si vous parlez
moi j'ai des amis polonais outre le
gouvernement polonais la première
angoisse de la Pologne qui ne l'oublion
pas a été rayé de la carte européenne
pendant 120 ans de son histoire c'est
qu'après les Ukrainiens ils soient les
prochains sur la liste donc je pense que
c'était une erreur massive de campagne
et bien évidemment et Donald Tusk l'a
dit dans la campagne soutient à
l'Ukraine et soutient à l'Ukraine dans
la durée comme le reste de l'Union
européenne alors il y a quand même la
Slovaquie aussi avec Robert fitzo hein
qui qui ne veut qui vient d'être élu et
va faire alliance avec l'extrême droite
et refuse l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine
et puis il y a toujours la Hongrie de
Victor Orban qui qui finalement a refusé
de participer au Conseil européen dont
on parlait à rencontrer Poutine et
cetera le front européen sur l'Ukraine
il a l'air quand même assez fissuré par
vous êtes en train de parler de deux
pays d'accord donc c'est le front
européen c'est 25/ 27 ce qui faut
remettre les choses à leur juste place
ça c'est la première chose et là Orban
très franchement il va un peu trop loin
ça n'est
pas il faut rappeler que quand on
bénéficie d'investissement chinois on a
un prix à payer après avec l'Union
européenne quand on bénéficie d'
investissement c'est pour faire partie
de cette grande famille et cette grande
famille qui respecte la démocratie et la
liberté justement parlons démocratie
avec des élections européennes le 9 juin
2024 dans quel climat j'ai envie de vous
demander on va on va les entamer est-ce
que c'est un climat d'létaire d'un foox
parce que il y a beaucoup d'unfox qui
circulent en ce moment effectivement et
avec quel message très différencié de
votre parti votre parti présidentiel
mais d'abord d'abord je veux vous
remercier parce que vous vous parlez
d'Europe et on ne parle pas assez de
l'Europe alors que l'Europe c'est à peu
près un/ers de notre cadre juridique ce
qui est quand même beaucoup donc la
première chose que j'ai envie de dire
c'est aller voter aux élections
européennes le Parlement européen a du
pouvoir du pouvoir qui façonne à la fois
notre vie quotidienne sur l'instant dans
le court terme mais aussi sur la durée
la deuxième chose c'est c'est donc un
scrutin européen ça n'est pas un scrutin
français demi-mandat parce que comment
ça marche le Parlement européen ça
marche par des alliances pour faire
aboutir des textes et donc ce qu'il faut
s'assurer c'est d'être représenté par
des personnes qui vont faire aboutir qui
vont être capable de forger des alliance
et ça je vais être très clair ni
l'extrême droite ni l'extrême gauche ne
SAV faire ça de façon à pouvoir façonner
notre cadre notre destin commun qui est
celui d'être une grande région
démocratique unie diverse mais un
démocratique avec la transition
énergétique avec un modèle social à
préserver paraît d'ailleurs que la
question de la tête de liste
effectivement pour votre votre groupe
centriste tête de liste française n'est
pas tranché tout à fait entre d'ailleurs
Stéphane sjourné peut-être que le
commissaire Thierry Breton et vous-même
Laurence boun d'ailleurs vous êtes prête
à y aller si on vous appelle je vais
vous dire les élections européennes vous
connaissez la date j'imagine c'est le 9
juin nous sommes le nous sommes au mi
octobre ce n'est pas pour moi une
question de personne c'est une question
d'ADN de ce qui définit notre notre
majorité qui est la seule majorité
véritablement pro-européenne donc pour
moi le sujet aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
parle d'Europe et que chaque citoyen se
rendre compte de ce que fait l'Europe et
de ce que ne fait pas l'Europe parce que
l'Europe ne fait pas tout et qu'on
arrive à être clair à exposer les enjeux
et comener un vrai débat sur l'Union
européenne qu'on veut à partir de 2024
et puis sur le le bilan qu'on porte
puisque je crois qu'on est les seuls à
avoir un bilan aussi large que celui
qu'on apporte dans la corbeille de la
mariée parlons en tout cas d'un sujet
aussi du club des 27 qui pourrait
s'élargir qui pourrait s'élargir il y
avait une visite évidemment d'Emmanuel
Macron à à Tyrana un sommet des Balcans
occidentaux la France est pour cet
élargissement désormais hein c'est un
changement de de cap quand même mais euh
préconise des clubs qui avancent en
quelque sorte à plus plusieurs vitesses
enfin c'est comme ça que le comprennent
certains certains dirigeants des des
Balcans occidentaux qui qui se plaignent
finalement de de peut-être être rejetés
à la périphérie de ces clubs je ne crois
pas je crois pas vraiment pas j'étais
avec le président à Tirana toute
personne qui écoute ce que dit edirama
le Premier ministre almané il le dit
lui-même le chemin pour faire partie de
l'Union européenne est un chemin qui est
nécessairement long parce que c'est une
transformation profonde des institutions
pour qu'elle s'aligne sur nos
institutions européennes et c'est une
transformation profonde de la culture de
la façon de faire de la politique de
protéger les partis les partis
politiques d'éliminer la corruption
c'est un changement du système de
justice c'est un changement du système
criminel donc vous voyez c'est c'est
assez colossal comme changement ce sont
des changements que nous avons fait en
70 ans et qu' doivent rraperer très V
plus des tensions actuelle extrêmement
forte entre des pays comme la Serbie et
le Kosovo par ex et les tensions sur les
territoires qu'on peut avoir entre la
Serbie au Kosovo ou en
Bosnie-Herzégovine donc donc il n'y a
pas de la part de de ces pays euh je
dirais d'incompréhension sur la durée
que ça prend il peut y avoir une fatigue
parce que ça fait longtemps que ça dure
mais il y a beaucoup de réformes à faire
chez eux et puis il y en a à faire chez
nous parce que ce qu'on est en train de
faire c'est de changer l'Union
européenne et je crois qu'on se le
disait au début il y a des choses que
l'Union européenne doit faire il y a des
choses qu'elle ne doit pas faire et
c'est vraiment la question qu'on peut se
poser et là le président de la
République a obtenu un un grand succès
j'allais dire à Grenade puisque
l'ensemble des 27 a reconnu qu'il
fallait changer l'Union européenne en
même temps que les pays qui sont
candidats à adhésion se change pour
s'aligner sur nos institutions c'est un
travail qui va nous prendre 5 10 ans
peut-être merci en tout cas Laurence
boun de nous avoir expliciter tous ces
enjeux merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
on poursuit sur le thème de
l'élargissement du club peut-être
bientôt à 35 c'est notre débat partie
débat donc tourné à Bruxelles avec des
eurodéputés
merci de nous rejoindre ici à Bruxelles
au Parlement européen ils étaient 6 au
début de la construction européenne ils
sont désormais 27 et ils pourrai bientôt
passer à 35 l'élargissement du club
européen est un véritable serpent de mer
mais il a pris une acuité particulière
depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie les Européens ont dû promettre la
candidature à ce pays en guerre et
d'autres nations n'ont pas manqué
l'occasion de réclamer leur du la
Moldavie et la geéorgie voisine de
l'Ukraine d'une part mais aussi les six
pays des Balcans occidentaux qui
attendait à la porte de l'UE depuis près
de 20 ans en attendant cette Europe XXL
promet de poser des problèmes
institutionnels énorme et le couple
franco-allemand réclame une réforme de
l'Union avant d'intégrer de nouveaux
membres oui d'ailleurs nous en parlons
tout de suite avec nos invités zianaovco
bonjour vous êtes député européenne du
Parti populaire européen de la Croatie
he qui qui est un pays balcanique qui
est le dernier entrer dans le club
européen et qui ne veut pas refermer la
porte derrière lui ça c'est évident et
nous sommes aussi avec fabianne Keller
député européenne de renw Europe
c'est-à-dire la majorité présidentielle
en France qui souhaite un allergissement
sous conditions de réforme on va en
parler Fabienne Keller c'est un peu le
retour de refoul quand même on n'osait
plus parler élargissement car les pays
candidats semblaient longtemps très loin
de nous et puis la guerre en Ukraine a a
rebattu les cartes oui elle nous a
rappelé que le la mission première de
l'Union européenne c'est de consolider
des démocraties de les inclure dans un
ensemble qui les protège contre
l'agresseur et là l'agresseur voilà il
s'est révélé à l'occasion de la guerre
d'agression de de la Russie contre
contre
l'Ukraine que très habilement volodimir
Zelenski a demandé à rentrer dans dans
l'Union et que la Moldavie lui a emboîé
le pas elle qui est très menacé
également hein sur son
territoire créant c'est vrai une
actualité forte une actualité
politique comment est-ce qu'on la
décline en terme économique en terme
structurel dans l'Union européenne c'est
c'est toute cette question cet
élargissement sera-t-il total d'un coup
est-ce qu'au contraire ça doit être
progressif en fonction des politiques
quel rôle de la nouvelle communauté
politique européenne que Emmanuel Macron
a souhaité organiser donc 45
États-membres qui se se réunissent
maintenant pour la 3oè fois à Grenade
qui se sont réunis donc voilà un débat
qui est ouvert mais clairement la France
et l'Europe souhaitent stabiliser des
démocraties mais être exigeant aussi sur
des sujets tellement importants comme
l'état de droit par exemple alors
effectivement plusieurs questions se
pose avec cet élargissement mais d'abord
une question sur l'Ukraine zeliana Zovko
est-ce que l'idée c'est d'offrir une
adhésion expresse à ce pays seulement
pour des raisons de sécurité euh je
trouve qu'il faut aussi changer notre
rapport sur élargissement c'est ce
sommes nous qui qui on offert l'option
européenne à l'Ukraine et c'est pour
l'Europe qu'ils se battent c'est comme
les les pays de de l'Est comme tous les
pays de l'Est et de Sud qui se battent
pour protéger notre nos frontières
maintenant il y a cette bataille contre
terrorisme au sud nous avons un bataille
contre les valeurs euh décréteur
autoritaire qui qui qui se déroule en
Ukraine et c'est la bataille pour
l'Europe que qu'on a qu'on a rêvé quand
nous nous avons rêvé le projet européen
est-ce que est-ce que nous nous avons
oublié cette rêve ou nous sommes tournés
dans un bureaucratie euh sans fin pour
prolonger cette agonie qui qui veut dire
euh si nous voulons avoir quelqu'un dans
notre famille c'est comme vous vous
côtoyez une fille pendant quelques
années vous voulez pas les marier mais
vous vousoulez laisser traîner comme ça
et c'est ça c'est c'est mariage ou pas
et c'est c'est c'est la seule chose
qu'on doit décider ENF avec le balcan
d'est et avec deest ouraïne est-ce qu'on
veut avoir une famille ou on veut être
individuel euh
et euh perdre cette rêve que nos pères
on ont rêvé quand ils ont battu le
projet de union on est des très mauvais
fiancés vous l'avez compris Fabienne
Keller par cette métaphore d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'on doit ouvrir des
négociations d'adhésion en parlant de
mariage
justement rapidement avant la fin de
l'année et c'est-à-dire en fait ça
paraît un peu fou pour nos
téléspectateurs peut-être de négocier
chapitre par chapitre avec un pays qui
est en guerre et pourtant c'est c'est ce
qu'on s'apprête à faire oui c'est ça
peut apparaître compliqué mais le la
réalité nous impose hein de trouver
d'autres d'autres
solutions l'aspiration du peuple
ukrainien à l'Europe est je dois dire
extraordinaire c'était incroyable quand
volodimir Zelenski était au Parlement et
que physiquement il nous a partagé
l'aspiration de son peuple alors que le
dernier événement aussi émouvant c'était
la sortie des Britanniques donc voilà il
nous raelle combien l'Europe est
désirable après voilà par exemple la
lutte contre la corruption reste un
sujet majeur en Ukraine et un sujet
central pour les pays des des Balcans on
voit les difficultés qu'on a avec la
Hongrie si on a pas de justice
indépendante si on a pas d'expression
libre et en particulier de liberté des
des médias voilà nos démocraties ne
peuvent pas vivre sereinement donc oui
il y aura ouverture de de chapitres mais
adapté à la situation particulière de
l'Ukraine en même temps l'Union
européenne va évoluer elle a beaucoup
progressé dans le domaine de la défense
mais beaucoup de choses sont à venir et
là aussi c'est l'Ukraine qui nous a
imposé de réagirin alors queil n'y avait
pas eu de guerre à nos portes depuis la
fondation de de l'Union européenne donc
comme comme l'avait dit CIT Schuman ouou
Jean Mony l'Europe progresse à
l'occasion des crises elle est face à
une nouvelle situation elle va peut-être
-être avoir plus de 30 pays membres
bientôt elle doit donc changer sa
gouvernance son organisation et adapter
aussi les
négociation d'entrée dans l'Union à la
réalité des pays mais on a découvert à
l'occasion de la guerre que on avait pas
mal d'Erasmus ukrainien déjà chez nous
donc l'Europe elle est déjà présente
d'une certaine manière dans de nombreux
États candidats ziana Zovko vous êtes
favorable à un élargissement rapide pour
notamment des raisons de sécurité mais
Fabian Keller en parlait il y a aussi
d'autres critères à respecter l'État de
droit euh la lutte contre la corruption
donc est-ce que c'est pas un risque
d'aller trop vite dans cet élargissement
non il n a pas la risque il y a euh
seulement la manque d'ambition on avait
eu des un grande ambition avec les
leaders d'avant je je me rappelle très
bien président Shirak qui est venu dans
le PACT de stabilité qui a été créé à à
saraevo
99 sommet de Zagreb c'était la France
qui était euh en avance avec cette
initiative président shirac dans ce
moment-là il a connu et il a compris la
réalité et la la le bout stratégique de
l'argissement l'ambition il faut l'être
pour les gens comme notre Président
Madame ursoua vonderlin qui a dit qu'il
faut être visionnaire et dans son
discours
d'État union state of Union elle a dit
que qu'il faut avoir courage pour pour
aller avant avecg oui elle a dit ça il y
a le cas on a on a bien vu un peu un peu
distinct de l'Ukraine de la Moldavie
pays voisin aussi qui a pris le train
express de la candidature la Georgie qui
l'a pas eu et puis il y a les balcons
occidentaux qui attendent depuis
longtemps à la porte qui sont un peu
vexés mais avec des conflits ouverts par
exemple entre la Serbie et le Kosovo
c'est même plus des questions seulement
de corruption qui existent bien mais
même des questions de sécurité entre eux
qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur offrir comme
perspective vraiment ben rappelez les
conditions de l'entrée dans l' c'est pas
possible que deux étatsmembres soient en
conflit soit en menace entre eux voir en
en intervention dans l'autre État membre
c'est c'est c'est pas possible parce
qu'il y a eu un attentat terroriste au
Kosovo expliquons quand même voilà
perpétré par la la Serbie voisine en
tout cas c'est la thèse qui semble
correspondre à la réalité donc ça c'est
pas possible dans l'Union européenne
donc comment fonctionne la justice face
à cette réalité comment sur le passé le
travail de mémoire et de réconciliation
a été en fait n'a pas été pour l'instant
conduit c'est aussi la condition d'une
cohabitation où des chefs d'État devront
être l'un à côté de l'autre mais je
pense et notre premier ministre andreé
plenkovic c'est pourquoi il a vraiment
insisté avec président Macron de
continuer avec éargissement de d'avoir
cet approfondissement et d'ouvrir la
négociation avec Macédoine de Nord et
Albanie pour pour la sécurité c'est
surtout la la la la chose qui est la
plus important la sécurité la loi
électorale en bosnieherzégovine la la
balance entre les trois communautés
comme dans Irlande du Nord power sharing
en rangement tout ça fonctionne mais
même au sein de l'Union européenne vous
avez vu qu'est-ce que s'est passé avec
ça fonctionne quand même pas très bien
en Bosnie le partage du pouvoir au
communautarisme et cetera ça fonctionne
pas très bien hein mais mais c'est
seulement l'Union attirance de l'Union
européenne qui qui qui euh qui calme les
choses qui apais sû et c'est la
perspective d'entrée dans l'Union la
conditionnalité que met l'Union
européenne à un certain nombre de règles
de de fonctionnement du pouvoir de
disparition de service secret qui ne
serait pas contrôlé par un pouvoir
démocratique c'est ces conditions qui
peuvent peut-être mais ça n'a pas marché
jusqu'à présent enfin pas suffisamment
en tout cas faire progresser les Balcans
on l'a vu en Ukraine où il y a eu des
efforts c'est un pays qui où la
corruption est très était très présente
elle reste encore mais le gouvernement a
beaucoup avancé dans la nomination par
exemple d'un procureur indépendant comme
en Moldavie enfin dans cette volonté de
ne pas garder ce qui sont des blocages
dans le processus d'entrée dans l'Union
européenne une question structurelle
Fabienne Keller sur l'Union européenne
car la France et l'Allemagne sont
favorables à un élargissement rapide
mais est-ce qu'il faut mener des
réformes dans l'organisation de l'Union
européenne par exemple sur la fin du
vote à l'unanimité pour fluidifier et
bien les décisions au sein de l'Union
alors l'unanimité n'est pas appliqué sur
tous les dossiers mais vous savez
qu'elle reste appliquée sur un certain
nombre clés comm la fiscalité et que
d'ailleurs Victor Orban s'en sert pour
empêcher de fiscaliser les gafas alors
que ce serait une recette tout le monde
en a besoin après la pour faire du
chantage sur à peu près tous les autres
dossiers aussi on va dire absolument il
il s'en ser et il en abuse il existe une
majorité qualifiée est-ce qu'il faut
l'étendre mais ça c'est ça suppose un
changement des traités donc c'est un
processus lourd mais ça c'est un premier
sujet et un autre c'est la gouvernance
on aura en Conseil européen au Conseil
des ministres 35 personnes autour de la
table on aurait 35 commissaires mais
est-ce que c'est possible qu'un pays ne
soit pas représenté dans la Commission
européenne c'est c'est compliqué d'où
d'où l'intérêt de ce cet autre concept
qui peut se développer et avoir sa
légitimité plutôt sous l'angle
diplomatique et militaire qui est la
communauté politique européenne je pense
que par contte vous voulez pas en fait
madame zofco vous voulez pas plusieurs
cercles concentriques alors il y a un
cercle où on fait un peu de politique un
autre cercle où on fait l'union de
Schengen un autre cercle avec l'euro et
cetera vous avez peur d'une Europe à à à
plusieurs vitesses qui se qui se dessine
avec l'élargissement oui parce que ça ça
ça ne peut pas marcher l'Europe
plusieurs intérêts ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment un cœur un cœur dans
cette Europe que vous êtes pas
égalitaire que vous êtes pas dans la
même dans le même niveau et il y a une
discrimination à plusieurs niveau et
pourquoi euh les les pays les petits
pays ont avoir un intérêt de participer
dans dans cette Europe parce que la
personne est naïve quelle est quelle est
la quelle est l'opportunité pour nous de
d'exercer le le même le même niveau de
prendre la décision c'est comme
Parlement nous sommes tous les égos ça
n'importe pas de de de quel pays vous
venez vous êtes le le membre d'un groupe
quand j'étais ambassadeur j'étais touj
j'étais dans le même niveau comme les
autres ambassadeurs il n'y a pas la
différence et c'est pourquoi c'est c'est
humiliation la l'Europe a plusieurs euh
vitess alors c'est même mieux parce que
quand on est un petit pays on est plus
nombreux au Parlement européen que quand
on vient d'un grand pays à cause des des
règles internes à l'Union pour que
toutes les
sens est-ce que vous êes est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à cette Europe à
plusieurs vitesses que dénonce ziana
Zovko alors moi je dirais pas à
plusieurs vitesses c'est que l'objectif
c'est pas de stabiliser un
fonctionnement à plusieurs niveaux mais
je pense qu'il faut une forme de
réalisme la Moldavie a l'Ukraine ont un
niveau de vie beaucoup plus bas que la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie aujourd'hui les
intégrés immédiatement par exemple dans
le marché unique ce serait fragiliser
leurs économies d'avoir probablement des
fites de talent massive ce qui est déjà
connu hein dans dans certains
États-membres actuels de de l'Union et
qui pénalise le pays pour se moderniser
pour avoir de bons de bonnes structures
dans l'état dans la dans la justice dans
les dans les entreprises pour garder des
compétences donc il faut avoir une forme
de pragmatisme mais avec un objectif
clair qui est d'intégrer complètement
c'est pour ça par exemple qu'aujourd'hui
moi ma mon pays se Batt pour l'entrée de
la Roumanie et de la Bulgarie dans
Schengen parce que c'est nature ils ont
fait les efforts ils doivent entrer
c'est pareil à terme pour les pays qui
sont candidats l'objectif c'est de les
accompagner pas d'accord P pas faire de
concession sur un sujet aussi important
que l'État de droit qui malheureusement
malgré les demandes depuis 20 ans reste
un sujet majeur dans les pays des
Balcans rapidement pour concl je sais
pas je sais
que je je comprends votre argument mais
je trouve que c'est toujours la
bureaucratie ici à Bruxelles les
politiciens qui se bat pour sa position
ce sont pas les gens et c'est c'est la
manque d'imagination qu'il faut euh
qu'il faut ouvrir les marchés qu' qu'il
y a l'opportunité là-bas il faut
réfléchir comme les États-Unis ah c'est
c'est le pays avec 500 millions de gens
et qu'ils n'ont pas peur d'avoir de de
changer tout le temps euh pour s'adopter
à la géopolitique d'jd'hu nous sommes
d'accord sur la stratégie c'est-à-dire
être un ensemble politique en terme de
géopolitique c'est central c'est
vraiment l'idée de la communauté
politique après sur la partie plus
techniques des intégrations de marché
faisons-le de manière aussi positive que
possible pour que cette
intégration regardez Afrique on a échoué
partout regardez qu'est-ce que la Chine
fait vous regardez les marchés partout
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire nous manquons
les gens nous manquons les gens avec des
SKS gens qui vont voyz dere marché les
compétences nos nos gens intelligents
ils s'en fuent aux États-Unis et ça ça
c'est le problème il faut vraiment être
compétent il faut pas avoir le peur il
faut se déburaucratiser il faut finir
avec les histoires anciennes parce que
moi je pense qu'on ne vit pas dans le
moment réel merci on a très bien compris
que vous étiez plutôt d'accord sur
l'élargissement mais pas sur ces
modalités merci à vous d'avoir très bien
illustré ce débat merci à vous nous
avoir
[Musique]
suivi